la fiscalía general de méxico abrió
varias investigaciones contra el ex
presidente enrique peña nieto- semanas
después de que la agencia controlada que
controla el lavado dinero de ese país
acusar al ex mandatario de manejar
billones de dólares en fondos
posiblemente ilegal españa nieto es
investigado por delitos electorales
lavado de dinero y también
enriquecimiento ilícito si el mandatario
si el ex mandatario mejor dicho es
llevado a juicio se trataría entonces de
un proceso histórico en ese país ya que
muchos ex mandatarios han sido acusados
de corrupción pero ninguno de ellos ha
sido juzgado saludamos entonces a
nuestro primer invitado del día del
gerardo rodríguez director de relaciones
internacionales y ciencia política de la
universidad de las américas en puebla
gracias a eduardo por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de francia 24 buena
mañana de miércoles las implicaciones
entonces que tiene esta investigación
contra el ex presidente enrique peña
nieto- y también digamos el precedente
que sienta esto en el país
gracias recordar que en méxico han
existido los llamados pactos de
impunidad
el presidente saliente es protegido por
el presidente que entra no importando el
color político de ellos no entonces si
es un antecedente muy importante
lópez obrador lleve una investigación
contra su antecesor a través de la
unidad de inteligencia financiera que
como sabemos llevan los los delitos las
investigaciones por probable el lavado
de dinero
operaciones con recursos de procedencia
ilícita pero estas acciones van sobre
todo a investigar cuando el presidente
peña nieto era gobernador del estado de
méxico la entidad más grande y con más
recursos de todo el país ahí se le acusa
de haber desviado millones de dólares
para la construcción de una carretera o
una empresa española o hl que al parecer
trasladó millones de dólares a cuentas
en españa sobre todo en andorra que
fueron terciadas por su abogado juan
collado y eso explicaría la fortuna que
tiene peña nieto- con la que vive en
españa en europa y en eeuu
digamos que además de estos
señalamientos cuáles son otros cero que
se le acusa al ex mandatario además
recordemos gerardo que esto que está
ocurriendo ahora fue digamos una de las
campañas una de las banderas que decía
el presidente lópez obrador en su
campaña presidencial antes de llegar a
la presidencia que decía que iba a
llevar entonces a la justicia a todos
los presidentes a los ex presidentes
mejor dicho que han sido corruptos en
mexico
hay otros casos de corrupción que están
siendo investigados y que han llevado ya
a la cárcel inclusive a la ministra de
bienestar social del país a rosario
robles también por haber desviado
recursos
para el partido en ese entonces en el
poder de peña nieto el pri hay otra
investigación también en cursos sobre
desvíos hacia una empresa de la familia
de peña nieto que recibió contratos
millonarios ahora sí durante su gobierno
como presidente de la república entonces
son varias las líneas de investigación
que puede llevar a cabo la fiscalía
general de la república que ya es un
órgano autónomo del estado mexicano sin
embargo ante todo esto gerardo el ex
presidente peña nieto sigue insistiendo
en su inocencia que pues se le tuvo todo
ese dinero y el dinero que tiene ha sido
puede ser todo legal no hizo ningún
lavado de dinero pero realmente que tan
implicado estaría el presse el ex
presidente de peña nieto en todas estas
investigaciones
activos de desvío de los recursos
públicos del estado y cómo podría salir
entonces el expresidente peñanieto de
todo esto
el presente peña nieto durante toda su
trayectoria ha sido político entonces no
se entiende como amasado esa fortuna
para tener casas de lujo en españa vivir
sin sueldo presidencial porque tenemos
que recordar que el presidente de lópez
obrador les quitó la pensión a todos los
expresidentes
hay otro caso también el que puede estar
involucrado el presidente peña nieto y
es el caso odebrecht méxico es el último
país de la región en avanzar en estas
investigaciones
hoy también se encuentra en la cárcel el
ex director de la empresa paraestatal de
petróleos méxicanos pemex y que también
ha involucrado en algunas declaraciones
testimonios ante la fiscalía general de
la república el probable la probable
participación o instrucción de parte del
presidente enrique peña nieto- en este
gran caso de corrupción de esta empresa
brasileña en toda américa latina la
fiscalía general d anunció que antes de
hacerse pública no todas estas
investigaciones ya tenían dos años
investigando todo esta entramado de
corrupción que salpica al ex presidente
enrique peña nieto cuando digamos que se
pudiera procesar y anunciar una
acusación formal contra el ex mandatario
pues mira la información y las
investigaciones iniciaron desde al menos
hace tres años cuando santiago nieto del
titular de la unidad de inteligencia
financiera el problema es que había muy
mala relación entre la fiscalía general
de la república entre el fiscal gertz
manero que también es acusado por casos
de corrupción y de nepotismo
dentro de la administración entonces
creo que ya tiene una información muy
sólida y
corroborada con las redes de tráfico de
influencias del lavado de dinero en
méxico y en el extranjero
gerardo peña nieto- pudiera regresar a
mexico digamos para enfrentar a la
justicia en un momento dado
yo veo muy difícil que el presidente
peña nieto regrese a méxico por esta
situación el estar al menos en españa-
podría retardar un poco en caso de que
haya una orden de extradición hacia
nuestro país y actualmente también
podría ir se esconderá israel por
ejemplo un país en el que ha habido
impunidad en el caso de algunos ex
funcionarios vinculados con espionaje y
también lavado de dinero así es que no
creo que el presidente peña nieto- tenga
interés de regresar a un país que lo
está persiguiendo que al menos lo está
investigando digamos si esto no sucede
entonces esa peña nieto no podría pagar
las consecuencias de pues éste esté todo
entramado de corrupción que lo salpica
pues mira los mexicanos estamos
esperando que eso suceda creo que el
gran voto de confianza hace tres años
hacia el candidato lópez obrador era por
su promesa de limpiar al país de la
corrupción y el país no puede transitar
a gobiernos transparentes no corruptos
si no hay un castigo ejemplar que
castigue este pacto de impunidad entre
presidencias de la cual te había
platicado al inicio